llamados a las urnas para elegir un
nuevo presidente 35 millones de
costarricenses deben escoger entre el
candidato conservador rodrigo chávez y
el centrista josé maría figueres lo que
a ustedes les está causando un enorme
malestar y sufrimiento falta de trabajo
nosotros sí vamos a crear trabajos de
una manera sostenible una pésima noticia
al narcotráfico y es que estoy a punto
de convertirme como presidente de la
república en su peor pesadilla
contra el narcotráfico iremos de frente
y con todo los colegios electorales
están abiertos desde las 6 de la mañana
y cerrarán a las 6 de la tarde entre los
problemas que enfrentará el próximo
presidente están una deuda externa que
representa el 70 por ciento del producto
interno bruto una tasa de pobreza del 23
por ciento un desempleo del 14 por
ciento lidiar con una creciente
corrupción en el sector público y
recuperar el sector turístico motor de
la economía y golpeado por la pandemia
ambos candidatos son dos lobos de la
política y tienen un pasado que
ensombrece su imagen
chávez exministro del gobierno saliente
fue sancionado por acoso sexual cuando
trabajaba en el banco mundial entre 2008
y 2013 figueres quien fue presidente
entre 1994 y 1998 fue acusado de recibir
por parte de la empresa francesa alcatel
novecientos mil dólares para que fueran
favorecidos en contratos en primera
vuelta el 60% de licencia electoral
asistió a las urnas la cifra más baja en
décadas aunque figure es dinero la
primera ronda serán los indecisos que
suman el 18 por ciento de los votantes
los que definirán quién será el nuevo
mandatario sin importar el ganador
ninguno de los dos tendrá mayoría en el
parlamento y el futuro presidente tendrá
que buscar alianzas con los otros
partidos